j'aimerais qu'on parle du cyber
harcèlement parce que kenza est avec
nous et c'est vrai que tout le monde a
parlé de cette ligue du lol vous êtes
l'une des premières victimes de cette
ligue du lot d'un groupe facebook créé
dans les années 2000 composé de
journalistes qui disait sérieux voilà on
a vu voilà que c'était des ddd des
charlots qui nous ont également beaucoup
tapé dessus
salim et ce à tous les blocs comme ça
insupportable
ça nous ils nous ont beaucoup tapé
dessus depuis mi février les membres du
groupe sont accusés par plusieurs
personnes de cyber harcèlement au groupe
tous les médias ont parlé de cette
affaire regardez et vous allez nous
raconter ce qui vous est arrivé c'est
une digue du lol
un groupe facebook qui date de 2013 un
groupe facebook fermé réservé à ses
membres une trentaine de personnes
surtout des hommes des journalistes de
publicitaire de graphisme de petites
frappes pseudo intello qui il ya
quelques années et bien occuper leurs
journées à harceler des personnes sur
les réseaux sociaux
un humour pour le moins douteux qui
n'est que la partie émergée de l'iceberg
car les attaques les plus graves
apple allen photomontage dégradant
divulgation de données privées ont été
postés sous des comptes anonymes et sont
difficilement traçables alors kenza
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
blogueuses mode qu'est ce qui vous est
arrivé raconter à nos téléspectateurs
alors pour moi ça a démarré en 2013
j'étais déjà très actif sur les réseaux
sociaux puisque je tiens un blog mode
depuis 2008 et du jour au lendemain je
me suis retrouvé avec un tweet de
truites trois tweets et 50 mentions par
jour sans mention par jour et c'est
plutôt dévalorisant alors au départ on
met ça sur le compte de l'humour et on
se rend compte que c'est plus l'humour
parce qu'on dépasse un peu les limites
ça devient des montages pornographiques
ça devient effectivement des appels à la
haine auprès des communautés des gens
qui twittait ça reprenait mais article
sur le blog que ça détourne et ça
reprenait mais vidéo ça les détourner et
c'est monté crescendo comme ça ça a duré
pendant deux ans jusqu'à ce que je
enfin je me retrouve finalement avec un
tweet qui m'appelle à agir le premier
truc qui m'a fait réagir sur lequel on
m'insultait de [ __ ] très ouvertement
j'avais jamais réagi jusqu'à présent
parce que je voulais rester plutôt digne
et je pense est en fait restée seule
dans mon cas je me disais bon je suis
blogueuse son journaliste donc forcément
dans l'imaginaire je suis pas très
intelligent je parle de futilité et en
fait j'ai été très surprise de me rendre
compte qu'on était tout un tas de
personnes à être victime de cette ligue
du lol quoi et c'est largement suis un
peu voulu ne pas avoir réagit en temps
et en art parce que ça n'a pas forcément
touchés comme ça à toucher d'autres
personnes je m'en suis rendu compte en
lisant les témoignages
mais j'ai constaté voilà je check and
has been dans mes rêves depuis que j'ai
4 ans c'est un peu violent et beaucoup
feu très violent ça serait journal us
elle je crois pas elle je pense que
c'est tellement fallait donc apprécié et
et voilà m partout mais ça traduirait la
sidération que peut avoir une victime
dans un flot de notification parce que
on en parle on parle de hordain c'est à
dire quand il parcourait cette meute là
va venir voir celer régulièrement
continuellement et pas simplement une
fois de temps en temps c'est
l'accumulation de cette haine l'un qui
alors que ça ça peut détruire quelqu'un
puisse signer ce que des solutions sur
ça moi je dis et éduquer informer
pénalisés et tout ça en même temps et
pendant 10 ans pour avoir des résultats
je suis optimiste toute la france n'est
pas raciste les gens ne sont pas tous
racistes
heureusement heureusement appuyons nous
sur eux ceux qui aiment les autres parce
que le racisme et l'antisémitisme n'est
dans la l'intolérance l'intolérance
l'ignorance entre haine l'intolérance et
l'ignorance voilà on n'aime pas la
différence le plus petit le plus gros le
roux des les enfants dès la maternelle
en quatre ans les enfants reprennent les
les parents les enfants et je les
entends donc éduquer informer est
pénalisé sur les réseaux sociaux
beaucoup plus la rumeur se fait insulter
sur les réseaux sociaux sans être
pénalisés quand on se rappelle de
christiane taubira qui elle
l'ancien élu rassemblement national
front national avait été avec juste une
petite amende de 3000 euros pénalisé
fortement éduquer informer
je crois en la france je crois à toute
la france qui n'est pas raciste
en 2000 ce pot
[Applaudissements]